welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Reacher season 1 meets Jack Reacher an
absolute giant of a man he's just come
to Georgia for some peach pie but he's
rudely interrupted by being arrested the
Harvard educated Tweed wearing detective
Finley fills him in there was a murder
late last night Reacher is suspect
number one cuz he's a mysterious Drifter
with no home address or possessions but
it's soon obvious Reacher's innocent
he's a retired war hero who just came to
town CU he loves blues music in fact
Reacher almost solves the case
immediately he was a military
investigator who's got Sherlock Holmes
likee powers of deduction the victim had
a phone number number in his pocket
which leads him to this Banker guy and
when he sees a mysterious car watching
him he confesses to the murder even
though he obviously didn't do it now
Richer's not free till his Alibi clears
so Finley forces him to help the
investigation he and the banker spend a
night in jail where he hopes the banker
will tell reard the truth but whatever
he's involved in is real serious as
inmates were already hired to kill him
so richer gives them to the count of
three one oh attacks immediately that's
his whole fighting strategy never
hesitate strike First Strike hard go BR
ey now that reachers alibi cleared he's
picked up from jail by the hot cop Rosco
he tells her about his wandering
lifestyle he's not a vagrant he's a hobo
and he enjoys having no possessions
whenever he needs to change his shirt he
just buys a new one so Reacher is
planning to Mosey on until he learns he
knows the victim it is his brother Joe
and now the case gets bigger when the
chief of police is murdered brutally
nailed to the wall now they realize
there's a vast conspiracy all the other
cops are probably dirty Reacher is the
only one they can trust first off Banker
guy disappeared they got to protect his
family so Finley calls in his FBI friend
who babysits them for the season their
top suspect is Mr Kleiner the rich guy
in town who seems real good and is
obviously bad especially because his son
KJ has been threatening Reacher even
though Reacher could crush his head with
one hand so they interview Kleiner but
can't find anything the only thing
suspicious is all the cow feed he
ordered a hell of a lot of cow feed for
not that many cows so Reacher keeps
investigating which mostly inails
beating people up he starts hanging out
with officer Rosco who hooks him up with
her uncle's gun an absolutely massive
Desert Eagle when the bad guys break
into her house she and Reacher go hide
in a motel where they start to fall in
love and pretty soon get it on but the
case keeps getting more complex what are
professional Venezuelan Hitmen doing in
this small Georgia town so Reacher gets
help from his old friend negly who was
in his special investigators unit back
in the military now somehow related is
the river pollution and when a dirty cop
captures him Reacher and negly get to
see the river real close up and now
Reacher has to change his shirt again
now Richer's brother Joe worked for the
Secret Service and when they talked to
his co-worker sgirl they learn he was
investigating counterfeiting she comes
to town to give them the files but no
the bad guys kill her too in New York
richer talks to the counterfeiting
expert who tells him it's the paper that
you just can't fake but the bad guys
have goons here too so Reacher kills
this guy with his neck tie then has to
change his shirt again so it's starting
to come together Mr Kleiner is running a
vast counterfeiting Network where
they're shipping fake money down to
Venezuela but when Finley goes to his
office to find evidence so Mr Kleiner
was already killed he wasn't the top dog
so Reacher lays a trap by telling one of
the corrupt cops where he's going to be
then he goes into Commando mode so when
the hit squad comes for him Reacher's
doing the hitting but during the fight
Reacher got knocked into the pool and
now his not paper is all faded and
that's the final puzzle piece how are
they getting the money paper they're
just using $1 bills washing the ink off
then reprinting them as hundreds and
that's what all the cattle feed was for
using it to dry the paper but the bad
guys are one step ahead cuz Finley's FBI
friend was in on it the whole time and
it's Kleiner Jr who killed his dad and
took over the operation cuz he's a
little psychopath but they're not
killing Reacher yet they need his help
to find the banker guy who they didn't
kill he's in hiding but Reacher sneaky
grabs a fork to pop the tire then in the
trunk grabs a gun and gets away then the
time for subtlety's over as Reacher and
Friends attack the warehouse and go in
guns blade in the final showdown with KJ
he's distracted monologuing about
hunting a rhinoceros so richer just
grabs this Punk throws him in the fire
avenges his brother and the day is saved
now richer and Rosco have fallen in love
but he can't stick around he's got to
keep wandering and she's like yeah I
figured this kind of seems like a James
Bond thing where you have a new hot
girlfriend every season so richer
finally gets his peach pie then leaves
town for his next adventure and that's
where Reacher season 1 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and
movies